- Dude, Damian!
- Hey, Drew!
- What's up?
- Yeah, how you doing, man?
- Dude, I just saw you!
- Yeah, I know, that vegan
beer festival was insane!
- Bananas, dude!
- (chuckles) Yeah!
- Hey, we should probably hang out more.
- Oh totally, I gotta run right now,
but we should totally hang out.
I'll hit you up.
- Yeah, man, do your thing.
- Take it easy.
- Let's hang out.
- Hang out!
- All right!
(melodic music)
- No way!
- Dude!
We gotta hang out.
- Yeah, let's do it!
- All right.
- Peace.
- (Damian) Hang out!
- Hang out!
- (Drew) Dude!
- Dude!
- Hang out!
- Text me!
- Yeah!
- No way!
- Hang out!
- Hangin' out!
- It's happening!
- Happening!
- Oh my God, dude!
- Dude!
- No way!
- [Damian] Let's hang out!
- Damian!
- Dude!
- Hang out!
- We gotta hang out!
- Damian!
- Drew!
- Dude, are we hangin' out or what?
- Damian?
- Hey man, how you doin'?
- Good, how you doin'?
- We gotta hang out!
- We gotta hang out, absolutely.
- We'll get together, we'll hang out.
(engine roars away) Oh
shit, that's my bus.
I'm sorry, man! I gotta go.
- Okay, I'll text you
and we'll get together
and we can hang out.
- [Drew] We're gonna hang out!
- [Damian] Good, man!
(morose music)
- Aw, dude, we should of hung out.
- Drew!
- Ed?
(laughs)
Dude, we should hang out, huh?
(upbeat Jazz music)